-Welcome back, everybody!
I'm about to play you some
real songs from real bands
that I think
that you should avoid.
It's time for my
"Do Not Play List."
Here we go.
-♪ Do not play, do not play ♪
♪ Do not play these songs,
these songs ♪
-Now, before we start, I just
want you to know that every
artist and song that I'm about
to play for you is 100% real.
These are actual bands.
They really are.
Quest, I swear they are.
They're actual bands
and actual songs.
You can get them
wherever you get music.
Spotify.
-Sure.
-Amazon.
-Yeah.
-They are real. Alright.
Let's see what's on my
Do Not Play list.
This first is from an artist
called Tanna Lou Cat.
[ Laughter ]
Also known as TLC.
-Yeah.
-That's a little false
advertising right there.
"Oh, you got the new TLC?"
Yeah.
But also, if you look down here,
it says it's got
"14 cool cat songs"
featuring all your favorite
artists
like Linda Petty --
-Oh!
-...Gregg Smith...
-Yeah.
-...Will Barnes,
Marc Stuart, and more.
-Yeah.
-Everyone's on this album.
-Greg Jensen.
-Greg Jensen's on there.
-Fart Clarvin.
-Fart C-- dude.
Steve Finson's on here.
-Oh, my God, Mark Jensen --
-Mark Jensen's on there.
-Terri Thinson.
-Aw, everyone is on this album.
They put the names on the cover
so you can buy it.
-I'm like, "Wait --
Is Gregg Smith on that one?"
-Yeah. Gregg with two G's?
-Yeah, two G's Gregg.
-Gregg with two G's?
Yeah, he's on here.
I'm pumped for it.
Let's listen to
"Walking Fur Factory."
-♪ W-W-W-W-W-W-Walking
fur factory ♪
♪ Fur factory ♪
-♪ If you own a cat,
then you know this ♪
♪ In the middle of the summer,
it's really the pits ♪
♪ 'Cause a cat's gonna shed
its fur for free ♪
♪ A cat is a walking
fur factory ♪
♪ Whoa, look out
when my cat comes near ♪
♪ Ain't nothing safe
when he sheds his hair ♪
♪ Clean black socks,
a solid white dress ♪
♪ Cat rubs against you,
it's a big hairy mess ♪
-Stop, stop, stop, will you?
-My God.
-Wow.
He really jammed that last line
in there.
-Yeah.
He had to throw it in there.
-♪ Clean black socks,
a solid white dress ♪
♪ Cat rolls up,
it's a big hairy mess ♪
[ Laughter ]
-You'd think they'd have
MC Skat Kat on there.
-If you are, though --
If you are wearing a white dress
with black socks,
a cat may not be for you.
[ Laughter ]
Next up is a band called
Billy Hay & The Chaos.
-Ah! Wow.
-Great name.
-Here's a nice stretched-out
photo of a fox.
-Yeah.
-With his tongue out, there.
-Make sure that fits
a 16x9, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's take a listen
to "Crazy Like a Fox."
♪♪
-♪ Every day on my way
out the door ♪
♪ Looking for more,
the big store ♪
♪ The big bang, the bing-a-bada,
the whole enchilada ♪
♪ Yeah, I am what I am
and I'm down with that jam ♪
-Alright. Stop, stop, stop.
-Wait, what?
Wait, is that spoken word
poetry or --
-I don't know what --
It sounds like he's just...
-Saying phrases.
-I think he's just got, like,
a rhyming dictionary.
"I'm on my way every day,
eating hay."
I don't -- "Ocean Spray."
[ Laughter ]
"Tina Fey."
-"Cranberry O.J."
-Yeah.
This one is...
This is a singer
called Nanci Nanci.
-Nanci Nanci?
-Yeah, there's Nanci Nanci
walking down the street.
-Ah. Not looking so fancy.
-Look at that dude.
The name of this song
is "I Know Whatcha Want."
-Whatcha? C-H-A?
-"I Know Whatcha Want."
-♪ Hey, boy,
I know whatcha want ♪
♪ But'cha not gonna get it
from me ♪
♪ Come on, boy, I'm no toy ♪
♪ Be a man,
put a ring on my hand ♪
-♪ Hey, Nanci Nanci ♪
-♪ Yeah, treat me right ♪
-♪ Hey, hey, Nanci Nanci ♪
-♪ Ah, nice ♪
-That's pretty good.
-Isn't a ring on a hand
a bracelet?
[ Laughter ]
Technically...
-No, but she means --
I'm don't know when the thing
came out,
but this probably
is a precursor to --
This is probably the original
"Single Ladies."
-You think Beyoncé is listening
to Nanci Nanci and going --
-I'm just saying,
Beyoncé, watch out.
-Yeah.
-'Cause Nanci Nanci
is coming up.
She's coming up.
Here we go.
This next one is an artist
called "No Frills."
-Oh, thank God.
I don't like frills.
-Yeah. Here's the album cover.
It's a banana.
-Yeah.
No frills on that album cover.
-No.
The name of the album is called
"Haulin' State of Mind."
-Wait. Haulin'?
Like moving things?
-Yeah, like a haulin' --
I'm in a haulin' state of mind.
-Like you want to move...
-It's a classic phrase.
-Yeah, yeah,
it's a classic riff.
-It's a classic phrase.
People say it all the time.
-Yeah. "Oh, man, how you doing?"
"I'm haulin'."
-I'm haulin'.
Yeah, what's up, man?
I'm in a haulin' state of mind
right now.
-I'm gonna eat a banana
with one bite.
One bite.
-So, the song in here
is called "Bananas."
-Sweet.
-Here we go.
Let's listen to it.
"Bananas."
-♪ Bananas ♪
[ Mid-tempo dance beat plays ]
♪ Bananas ♪
-♪ Gotta get a fix
of your potassium ♪
♪ Eat 'em in a haste
or savor one by one ♪
♪ Bananas, bananas,
the portable fruit ♪
♪ Put 'em in a smoothie
or your cold-pressed juice ♪
♪ Bananas ♪
-Stop, stop, stop.
Stop. Please, stop.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not bad.
-Come on.
That's a good line.
Banana, the portable fruit.
-The portable fruit -- 'cause
no other fruit is portable.
You can't take fruit
with you, man, yeah.
-♪ Try to pick up an apple ♪
-No good.
-[ Laughing ]
Wait, why is that
the portable fruit?
-Grapes don't travel.
[ Laughter ]
You gotta take the whole
vineyard with you.
Nobody can pick up a vineyard.
-How am I gonna hold
all these grapes?!
-I mean, what am I supposed to
do, pick up an apple tree?
-We got to eat it
right off the tree.
-I got a pumpkin patch
over here.
-Bananas for my cold-pressed --
cold-pressed juice?
You can't get juice
from a banana.
-No. There's no banana juice.
-Good luck. Good luck.
-This guy's totally off.
-Spending all day
juicing his bananas.
-No frills on research.
-Yeah.
-♪ Bananas ♪
-Alright.
We're down to our last song.
This one is from an early '80s
band from New Zealand
called "Monte Video
and the Cassettes."
That's a great name.
I'm assuming that's Monte
right there.
-Hoping.
-He looks like he's doing an
impression of either Borat or --
-Terry-Thomas?
-Looks almost like Borat and
Jeff Foxworthy almost.
Kind of, right?
But I like the look.
Anyway, let's take
a listen to --
-You might be a redneck.
-Shoop -- [ Chuckles ]
Let's take a listen to
"Shoop Shoop Diddy Wop
Cumma Cumma Wang Dang."
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
[ Upbeat music playing ]
-♪ Shoop shoop diddy wop
cumma cumma wang dang ♪
♪ Shoop shoop diddy wop
-Not that bad.
-Actually, this is pretty good.
-♪ Shoop shoop diddy wop
cumma cumma wang dang ♪
-I take it back.
I like this one.
This one's good.
I take it back.
I like this. Roots!
Alright, you guys.
Thank you very much.
That's all the time we have.
If you have an album or a song
you think we should use
in our next "Do Not Play List",
send it to us
at donotplay@tonightshow.com.
We'll be right back
with Robert De Niro.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Shoop shoop diddy wop
cumma cumma wang dang ♪
♪ Shoop shoop diddy wop
♪ Shoop shoop ♪
[ Laughs ]